[Applauso]
katia eccomi grandi veloci cambiamenti
velocissime velocissimi e cosa accada
gli adolescenti come vivono questa cosa
gli adolescenti cosa cosa succede
difficile dirlo perché
solitamente si descrivono gli
adolescenti di oggi i modi opposti si
parla degli adolescenti raccontando
soprattutto i loro aspetti più
demotivati più superficiali
si raccontano noi vi raccontiamo come
ragazzi svogliati fragili oppure li
decantiamo quando abbiamo in mente delle
straordinarietà dei personaggi fuori
dalla norma allora c'era innamoriamo
senza riuscire ad avere una visione che
porti queste specialità all'interno del
grande gene della grande generazione
attuale se dobbiamo invece fare i conti
con le richieste d'aiuto e il
coinvolgimento dei clinici dobbiamo
pensare una generazione che
sostanzialmente è più triste delle
generazioni di adolescenti precedenti è
più chiusa meno incline alla ad
esprimere in modo esteriore la rabbia e
l'aggressività quindi sono meno propensi
a lottare a gridare sono più a rischio
di invece chiudersi in un in una
chiusura che è un ritiro dal progetto di
crescita di una tristezza che li lascia
demotivati
forse sarebbe interessante un esempio
per farci capire
credo che l'esempio gli esempi che
purtroppo molti di noi conoscono non
solo che si occupa di clinica tra i
nostri parenti cugini amici sono le
storie di ragazzi che in realtà sono
stati bambini speciali sono bambini che
vengono descritti alle materne alle
elementari come
in termini entusiastici sono quel
bambino che
simpatico veloce rapido sempre in
movimento con le idee chiare che forse
si fa fatica veramente a gestire però
insomma si intravede che ha un carattere
che ha una personalità e che forse ha
destinato a non stare nei ranghi a non
sottomettersi
forse sarà anche quello che riuscirà ad
avere come dire la capacità di trovare
una strada meravigliosa ed è un bambino
che quando arriva anche alle elementari
nonostante dica io mi occupo di questo
mi occupo di uccelli voglio occuparmi di
animali nostro è solo dinosauri in
ossola pesci questa cosa me non piace
questo è un segnale accolto con
soddisfazione perché vuol dire che
appunto le idee sono chiarissime sin dal
principio ed è in connessione con le
proprie predisposizioni fatto salvo che
poi quando si arriva alle medie lo
sguardo cambia completamente e quegli
stessi elementi che sono stati
utilizzati e accolti con favore e stati
utilizzati per dire wow guarda quanta
energia e guarda quante possibilità alle
medie registro cambia lo sguardo si
trasforma diventa preoccupato diventa
allarmato perché o dio non sta alle
regole oddio gli abbiamo dato delle
indicazioni non le segue forse
addirittura rimane indietro
nell'apprendimento proprio perché non è
in grado di sfruttare le tracce
utilizzate già da altri prima di lui e
quindi quello che era talentuoso poi
diventa allarmato preoccupato a volte
anche disgustato per cui gli adolescenti
vengono anche visti con questo tipo di
sguardo dai dai dagli adulti e questi
ragazzi che improvvisamente si si
scontrano con una visione che non
avrebbero mai sospettato perché
cresciuti invece in anni quasi dieci
anni di accoglienza e di sguardi
estremamente positivi prima cercano di
capire cosa è successo chi ha sbagliato
quelli che sono arrivati prima è che
forse hanno visto un talento che non
c'era una genialità che non c'era o
forse hanno sbagliato
quelli che sono arrivati dopo e che sono
ostili agli adolescenti e che quindi non
sono disposti ma sta di fatto che è un
quesito che poi perde rapidamente
importanza perché ciò che conta nella
mente di questo di questo bambino di
questi bambini è che comunque le cose
sono andate storte quindi loro
sicuramente hanno sbagliato qualcosa e
quindi possono vergognarsi per questo
atteggiamento e questa modalità modesta
che manifestano ma anche questa
incapacità di aver mantenuto le promesse
quindi vergogna e colpa si alternano ea
quel punto il dolore è troppo forte il
futuro non c'è più e quindi quello che
poi succede anche questi ragazzi si
chiudono smettono di pensare che il
progetto futuro sia esista o che abbia
veramente senso si soffre meno a ridurre
le aspettative a chiudersi in casa anche
per la paura di manifestare di
dimostrarsi agli altri che vedranno le
differenze di quando andavo alle
elementari bello contento e quando ora
invece mostri in tutta la drammaticità
la tua mediocrità non quindi un disastro
da un punto di vista del progetto del
progetto di crescita
ecco che cosa è andato storto cioè di
chi la responsabilità
da un certo punto di vista da tutti e da
nessuno nel senso che forse dobbiamo
ripartire accettando l'idea che sia il
valutazione positiva che la valutazione
negativa e nello sguardo di chi guarda e
non nell'individuo che ha guardato
noi abbiamo un problema molto serio oggi
noi adulti intendo abbiamo un problema
molto serio a modulare i modelli
educativi in modo coerente tra
l'infanzia e l'adolescenza e siamo gli
adulti che hanno sono si sentono traditi
perché hanno visto sfumare un futuro
garantito mi vien da dire certo devi
fare delle cose per fa per avere il
futuro un po di responsabilità un po di
impegno però poi quel futuro positivo
non era in discussione oggi invece lo è
il futuro che ci aspetta ci siamo
convinti che sia totalmente distrutto e
rovinato e siamo anche degli adulti che
hanno sperimentato sulla propria pelle
la drammaticità di insegnare le regole a
stare nella regola senza consapevolezza
senza pensiero quindi con un pensiero
dipendente con un pensiero che non
ragiona e non mette in una posizione
critica la regola che ti viene
prescritta e e questo ha determinato un
riversamento di noi adulti sui bambini
sui piccolissimi che dicendo loro che
devono avere coraggio che devono essere
forti che devono cercare rapidamente
prestissimo i loro talenti per diventare
se stessi per cercare una loro strada e
in modo tale che che tu che tutto quello
che poi sarà di difficoltà diventerà
anche però un qualcosa che loro sono in
grado di superare non abbiamo fatto i
conti con l'adolescenza perché
l'adolescenza rispetto all'infanzia
mette in campo il diverso
l'altro non conosciuto e quindi
valorizzare un bambino per noi che gli
stiamo insegnando la regola nella
relazione fai questo perché io ti voglio
bene fai questo perché io molto
investito per inter e io so qual è il
tuo bene e quindi è una regola che sta
all'interno di un ambiente che
conosciamo e che investiamo di valore
perché ci appartiene ma l'adolescente è
destinato se fa bene il suo mestiere ad
andare oltre ad andare verso lo
sconosciuto il diverso l'inesplorato e
lì noi adulti che siamo ancora dentro la
l'abitudine a fare i garanti della
crescita perché conosciamo le regole
conosciamo la responsabilità ci
spaventiamo
noi non sappiamo che pesci pigliare che
dovremmo dire ea quel punto torniamo al
vecchio modello torniamo a sotto a
chiedergli di sottomettersi alla regole
in nome della responsabilità in nome del
diventare adulti
gli chiediamo di aderire al nostro
modello che abbiamo buttato via perché
abbiamo visto che non funzionava ma non
ne abbiamo uno alternativo e siamo in
mancanza di meglio
chiudiamo senza renderci conto che in
questo modo
chiudiamo la possibilità di creare una
apertura verso il futuro visto
l'esperienza la quantità di casi che che
analizzato hai vissuto ed è aiutato che
cosa si può fare tante cose
fortunatamente perché i ragazzi ritirati
sono un numero sempre crescente
i ritirati sociali sono una caratteri
sono una quota sono quelli che sono
chiusi in casa ma ci sono sempre più
anche casi di ritiro mentale inteso come
uno chiudersi e non pensare proprio per
non sentire il dolore
dobbiamo davvero ricominciare con la
consapevolezza che siamo noi gli attori
che possono spostare l'ago della
bilancia
il progetto di dare così tanto valore ai
bambini e poi toglierlo agli adolescenti
immaginando di dare in questo modo agli
adolescenti un po di prove in cui
rafforzare il carattere in cui in cui i
temporali in realtà è un progetto
suicida per per le adolescenti attuali
perché vuol dire averli radicati dentro
la relazione dentro lo sguardo e poi
improvvisamente senza preannunci di
nessun tipo togliergli quella
quell'appoggio togliergli quell'area di
solidità che è la relazione con gli
adulti in generale i significativi ma
anche gli insegnanti e tutti gli adulti
che hanno intorno
e quindi vuol dire consegnarli alla
paura e alla solitudine alla tristezza
poi abbiamo un altro problema serio che
ha dato dalla velocità qui tu facevi
accenno nell'introduzione e la velocità
dei cambiamenti e tale da avere reso le
istituzioni e averle collocate in una in
una situazione molto difficile perché è
evidente che oggi noi la conoscenza la
dobbiamo modificare dobbiamo considerare
una conoscenza non come l'abbiamo vista
noi e non come l'abbiamo imparata ancora
scuola che è una conoscenza fatta di
contenuti fatta di passaggi lineari
fatta di rapporti tra chi sa e chi non
sa che deve imparare che quindi deve
ricevere quei contenuti e deve imparare
a ripeterli oggi la conoscenza è
evidente che è una conoscenza
processuale in cambiamento in evoluzione
ha bisogno di esplorazione ha bisogno di
menti riflessive ha bisogno di menti che
sperimentano la conoscenza ecco che noi
siamo ancora collocati all'interno di un
modello quei libri alti negli scaffali
di cui si parlava questa mattina che non
sono in grado di in realtà costruire dei
dispositivi per allenare
veramente non si possono allenare
competenze complesse senza far sporcare
le mani e ragazzi e quindi senza
modificare i dispositivi e renderli
flessibili
abbiamo anche un altro problema che
riguarda sempre la conoscenza per come
immaginiamo noi noi adulti siamo
cresciuti nel sono dalla rivoluzione
tecnologica della scrittura noi abbiamo
un rapporto con la conoscenza che è
fatta di nomi fatta di definizioni fatta
di casistica di inscatolamento di
analisi differenze che ci dicono abbiamo
conosciuto questo concetto è questo lo
applichiamo a tutto anche quando diamo
un voto quando diamo un giudizio quando
diamo una una diagnosi quindi si sa che
siamo genitori insegnanti clinici in
realtà noi applichiamo una logica
tassonomica a questi ragazzi quindi gli
diciamo sei così 6 con la prima eri
geniale rito lento zoe poi
improvvisamente diventi uno che ci
spaventa un po che non sta nelle regole
forse non riusciamo nei tuoi confronti
che non sappiamo che cosa stai facendo
come facciamo a fare noi garanti di
questo tuo percorso che già parla di
argomenti di contenuti e poi di modalità
che non conosciamo ecco che allora gli
diamo l'etichetta senza renderci conto
che se l'identità oggi è diventata un
identità che è in movimento si diventa
se stessi e ci vuole una vita per
diventare sempre più un po noi stessi
abbiamo bisogno di adulti che si
interrogano sul significato profondo di
quel funzionamento non non è l'etichetta
che può aiutarci ci serve dietro
l'etichetta a ragionare del perché
succede questo e che senso ha e quali
risorse può puoi attivare come le hai
attivate
ultima cosa cioè l'ultima grande
tematica grande come una casa ma bisogna
forse provare a ri dircelo tra adulti
prima ancora di coinvolgere i ragazzi è
che noi in realtà abbiamo condannato
questi ragazzi quando erano bambini in
questo passaggio dalla famiglia formale
quella delle regole quella dei valori
assoluti alla famiglia affettiva quella
delle relazioni li abbiamo resi
dipendenti dal nostro sguardo siamo noi
che diamo valore e ha fatti quando poi
dopo ci spaventiamo glielo togliamo e
quindi sono ragazzi che dipendono
profondamente da noi e dalla nostra
felicità in qualche modo quindi quando
noi ci spaventiamo noi ci spegniamo
ci preoccupiamo e e dichiariamo che il
futuro a quel punto è tutto sbagliato è
tutto perduto
questi ragazzi non solo a quel punto
hanno un problema per la loro per la
loro sopravvivenza ma si sentono anche
gravati della responsabilità di averci
di averci in qualche modo deluso di
averci danni
e diventa un meccanismo scisso dove
tutti i soggetti sono sono ognuno da una
parte in angoscia e in difficoltà la
stessa come dire l'esempio più eclatante
di questa di questo correre ai quattro
cantoni tutti separati e l'idea che ai
ragazzi noi diamo sin da piccoli dicendo
trova il tuo talento trova la tua
specialità corre in fretta decidi prima
possibile quel famoso mio mi occupo dei
dinosauri piuttosto che no
nell'idea che la tua strada debba essere
concentrata su te stesso sulle tue
ambizioni oltre che sulle tue competenze
in realtà se quella conoscenza e una
conoscenza che va costruita vaco
sperimentata devi necessariamente
prevedere l'esistenza dell'altro devi
entrare in un progetto di
corresponsabilità della conoscenza
tanto è vero che oggi i ragazzi
rinunciano al progetto di crescita e
rinunciano il progetto di sapere se il
sapere loro è a discapito di qualcun
altro
diventa uno dei fattori di rischio più
alti in una classe quando è troppo
evidente che la competizione privilegerà
qualcuno e toglierà qualcun altro questo
è un elemento che puoi vederlo nel
singolo individuo o poi vederlo nel
grande gruppo perché non è soltanto
necessario a questo punto dire dobbiamo
dare spazio giovani perché giovani non è
vero che sono super superficiali
incapaci
sono invece forti hanno le tecnologie in
mano hanno il loro futuro ed e bisogna
partire da lì è il loro il futuro il
nostro come ce lo immaginavamo non
esiste più ma non possiamo neanche
toglierci come dire fare un passo
indietro e lasciare tutto le nero romani
perché sono ragazzi che abbiamo fatto
crescere nella condivisione nella
partecipazione delle emozioni ora
bisogna metterci partecipazione nella
costruzione non solo della conoscenza ma
anche del progetto futuro perché come se
dovessimo dire non è più come ci
aspettavamo è tutto diverso non sappiamo
neanche qualcosa succederà però se lo
facciamo insieme qualcosa
portiamo a casa è come dire che non
siamo garanti di tutto il processo ma
siamo garanti del fatto che ne vale la
pena
e che insieme possiamo comunque può
costruire un futuro bellissimo messaggio
[Applauso]
[Musica]